นะครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอาร์ตี้สวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนโอเคทำมาเจอกับครูตี้กับครู
พี่เอ๋ในช่องคอมเพรน Store ไทยอยู่ตรงนี้
โอเคถาม
สายขวาภัทรี
อายุด้านนี้เอา
อยู่ตรงอยู่ข้างบนพี่เอกพอดีๆน่าอยู่ตั้ง
นี้ของผมโอเค
ค่ะ
ก่อนที่จะเอานี้กินรีบพาไปเที่ยว
โอเคอ้าวันนี้เดี๋ยวไปกับพี่เอ๋บ้างน่ะนะ
ครับเราจะพาไปเที่ยวกันนะคะอ่าตอบก่อนจะ
ไปเที่ยวก็ต้องรู้ก่อนนะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอะไรล่ะครับเนี่ยนะกลัวตี้
ปฏิทินอยู่ไหนอ่ะอยู่นี่ครับวันนี้วัน
อังคาร
วันนี้วันอังคารขอราคารใช่ครับวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 14 เดือนอะไรคะ 5
เดือนมิถุนายนเหมือนเดิม
พ.ต.อะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ครับปีคศอะไรคะคะขอ
2022 ในตอนนี้เวลาอ้าเวลา 8:00 น 8:30 น
08:10 นนะคะ
นักเรียนตื่นพอดีนะคะ
นักเรียนนักเรียนตื่นกลัวแต่คิดว่าเริ่ม
ง่วงนิดหน่อยๆๆนักเรียนตื่นเพราะว่าเป็น
เวลาเช้านักเรียน
เรานะคะโอเคโอเคเดี๋ยวคลิปนี้แหละนะคุณ
ต้องตื่นสิครับเพราะเดี๋ยวเรากำลังจะไป
เที่ยวกันน่ะเห็นมีหลายๆคนก็รอที่จะไป
เที่ยวกับเรา
คุยรบกวนตีนนิดนึง
แผนที่แผนอ้าวแผนโอเคเธอไปไหนครับวันนี้
วันนี้ไปไหนรวมไปไหนไปไหนวันนี้อันนี้ล่ะ
คะกูเอ๋น่าจะพาไปภาคใต้
ไปพักใต้
ไปภาคใต้ใกล้ๆผู้เก็บในก็ตรงนี้อ่าใกล้ๆ
กูเกร็ดใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวกูที่ดูก่อนนะภูเก็ต
อยู่ตรงนี้
ภูเก็ตเป็นเกาะแล้วก็เป็นจังหวัดนะคะน่า
ได้ครับมีใกล้ๆกูเก็บโอเค
จะพาไปที่จะ
จังหวัดกระบี่ค่าจังหวัดกระบี่อยู่ตรงนี้
อยู่ใกล้ๆกับภูเก็ตจังหวัดกระบี่ศรีซีส
เสียในสีส้มสีส้มหรือสีครีมหรือสีน้ำตาลๆ
ก็ไม่รู้อยู่ตรงนี้อ้านี่นี่ๆฮ่าอะคือ
จริงๆเนี่ยที่ที่ครูเอกจะพาไปเนี่ยกว่า
ตี้อ่ะเป็นเกาะหาก็เกาะของจังหวัดกระบี่
ค้าแต่ว่าถ้านักเรียนไปเที่ยวเนี่ยนัก
เรียนสามารถไปจากภูเก็ตได้
บางคนก็บ่ไปเที่ยวเกาะอันนี้แล้วก็คิดว่า
เกาะอันนี้อยู่ที่ภูเก็ตจริงๆไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่นะเพราะว่าต้องนั่งเรือแต่กูเก็บไปที่
เกาะนี้อ๋อโอเคเป็นกระบี่กระบี่นามิเกาะ
โอเยอะมากนะคะต้องบอกก่อนพี่ก็อกเยอะมาก
และคู่เกย์เอามาบางส่วนนะคะไม่ได้เอามา
ทั้งหมดนะคะกลับมาเกาะที่ครูเอ๋ชอบค่ะน้อ
โอเคกอดที่สวยแน่ๆที่กูเห็นชอบเนี่ยอาจจะ
สวยหรือเคยสวยๆ
สไปซี่โอเคเดี๋ยวกูเอกขอ Share  screen
ได้ครับ
จริงๆจากกรุงเทพไปกระบี่นักเรียนสามารถ
อ่ะถ้าใครไม่ทักไข่ไม่ไปเที่ยวเกาะนี้โดย
ไปที่กระบี่ก็นั่งเครื่องบินนะเครื่องบิน
จากกรุงเทพไปภูเก็ตแล้วก็ซื้อซื้อถั่วค่ะ
ซื้อทัวร์แพ็คเกจทัวร์จากภูเก็ตแล้วก็ไป
เกาะนี้ได้
เกาะแรกเพราะอะไรครับก่อนนี้ว้าวสวยจัง
เลยชื่อว่าเกาะห้องเกาะห้องหอเป็นเกาะ
หรือเป็นห้องครับเป็นเกาะห้องเกาะชื่อ
ห้องแล้วเกย์เกย์หรือเรียกเกาะห้องอยู่
ตรงนี้กูอะตี้ขวดอื่นตรงนี้ไหมครับเขาไหน
นับในห้องอยู่ตรงไหนครับก็ตีก็ยังไม่เคย
ไปเลยพี่กระบี่หน้าแรกตรงนี้เข้าไปตรงนี้
เป็นห้องเห็นไหมอ๋อมีห้องอยู่ข้างในออก
เลยเรียกว่าถ้ามีน้ำคู่เอกเคยเข้าไปตรง
นั้น 1 ครั้งขอเป็นไงครับข้างในเป็นไงสวย
นะน้ำทะเลสวยมากกูก็อร่อย
เข้าไปกินปูที่นั่นแหละครับคือคือครูเอก
ตอนเข้าไปน่ะเคยไปแค่ครั้งเดียวตอนน้ำ
ขึ้นครับข้างในตรงเนี้ยเขามีน้ำขึ้นกับ
น้ำลงนะคะปกติก็ไม่ได้เข้าไปเที่ยวหรอก
เขาจะให้เที่ยวแค่ตอนนี้
แต่อ้ะก็มีช่วงที่ที่น้ำลงน้ำลงแล้วเขาก็
มีปูเดินต้องมีมีคนอ่าจับปูมาให้
กับกูแล้วเขาก็เลยเอามามันต้ม Like ชิม
โอ๊ยอร่อยมากอร่อยใช่ไหมเพราะว่าควรตี้
คิดว่าถ้าปูเนี่ยกูเท่ากินก็สดอร่อยมาก
ให้กูยังคิดถึงอยู่เลยอ่ะไม่เคยกินปู
อร่อยเท่ากันคือมันมีตัวเดียวและแบ่งกัน
10 คน
อร่อยเลยนะหิวด้วยหรือเปล่าครับตอนนี้
กำลังหิวด้วยนะเราเป็นเด็กอ่ะหรอเราเด็ก
เข้ามาให้เราใหญ่แล้วก็องค์อัลเลาะห์
เราทิปส์อะไรนะแบบที่จะไม่ค่อยมีนะคะนัก
เรียนปูเนี่ยจะไม่ค่อยมีเกาะจะค่ะถ้าจะไป
เที่ยวเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่เขาจะพาไปเที่ยวตรง
นี้ตรงไหนครับบริเวณนี้อ๋ออยู่ด้านหน้า
ไม่ได้เข้าไปในห้องใช่ไหมอยู่นอกห้อง
กูเองไม่แน่ใจว่าตอนนี้นะเขาพาเข้าไปข้าง
ในหรือเปล่านะคะแล้วแต่แล้วแต่บริษัท
ทัวร์
แล้วแต่ตอนกูแอบไปเที่ยวเนี่ยอ่านส่วน
ใหญ่ก็คือจะอยู่บริเวณนี้นะอย่ายุ่ง
บริเวณตรงนี้แหละ
นะคะมีชายหาดไม่รู้ยาวกี่
เป็น 1 กิโลได้มั่งอีกแน่ใจแต่ว่าไม่ไม่
ได้มากตรงเนี้ยเราก็ตรงนี้เป็นหน้าผาและ
แบบนี้เลยกู Arty น่ะอ๋ออ๋อปีนขึ้นไปได้
ใช่ไหมครับน้าให้หน้าผาสูงชันโอเคเวลาฝน
ตกเนี่ยคนไปเที่ยวจะกลัวเฮ้ยถ้าน้ำท่า
คลื่นมาบอกยังไงมาเส้นหนีไปทางไหนนะไม่มี
ที่หนีค่ะก็ไม่ได้
R คือเกาะห้องเนี่ยกูแอบชอบเพราะว่าอาจ
ใช้หานะทรายควรที่เห็นเนี่ยไปหาทรายเป็น
ไงครับตรงไหนตรงไหนเนี่ยทรายสวยมากกว่าดิ
ทรายขาวละเอียดเลยไหมครับใช่ขาวละเอียด
แล้วน้ำทะเลสีนี้เลยสีแบบ
สีเขียวอมฟ้าสีเขียวเขียวๆฟ้าปนกันใช่ไหม
ครับถ้าถ้าเห็นเป็นสีอันนี้ก็แปลว่าลึก
อันนี้ก็คือคือมากกว่า 10 เมตรแล้วเนาะ
หืออันเล็กลงไป 10  M บวกบวกนะคะถ้าแถว
นี้ก็อาจจะ 3 เมตร 4 เมตร
นะครับก็ก็มันจะเป็นแบบนี้หัวนี่ก็เป็น
แบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็ลึกเลยขอว้าวที่เราดู
เนี่ยเราไม่รู้แต่ถ้าเราว่ายน้ำหนังว่าย
น้ำแล้วใส่หน้ากากพระหน้าเราเราก็จะเห็น
เขาก็จะเห็นว่ามันลึกมากหรือนึกน้อยถ้า
เราว่ายน้ำอยู่ให้มันจะลึกงั้นเราสังเกต
ได้เลยตรงไหนที่มองแล้วมืดลึกอาหารลึกแน่
นอนได้ไหมที่นี้เนี่ย
บริเวณแถวนี้ค่ะครู Arty ตรงนี้ออกกำลัง
สักนี้ขอ
หมอ
เขาจะมีเกาะเล็กๆ
อ้ะคู๋ว่าเกาะห้องน้อยเกาะห้องเล็กห้อง
เล็กนะโอเค
ต้องนอนไม่รู้นะครับแล้วก็ตรงเนี้ยะเวลา
น้ำขึ้นน่ะเวลาน้ำขึ้นนะคะเดี๋ยวคุยลบตรง
นี้ก่อนถ่ายน้ำทะเลจะมีช่วงที่น้ำขึ้นสูง
และกะน้ำลงอ่า
เวลาน้ำขึ้นจะเห็นเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะอย่าง
เงี้ย
แล้วก็มีต้นไม้
นิดหน่อยนะคะก็ไม้นิดหน่อยน้ำขึ้น
เวลาน้ำลง
ฉันจะเห็นเยอะใช่ไหมครับใครค่ะเวลาน้ำลง
ก็จะเห็นเป็นแบบนี้
มันเห็นไปน่ะอ๋อ
คู๋น่ะบ่เคยเจอตอนน้ำลงเจอแต่ตอนน้ำขึ้น
ก็เห็นแต่ต้นไม้อยู่ข้างบนใช่ไหมเห็นเป็น
แบบนี้เห็นเป็นแบบนี้อ่ะเวลาไปก็จะเห็น
แบบนี้ทุกครั้งตอนคุยหารูปเจอแต่ตอนน้ำลง
ก็เลยไม่เอามา
ไม่ใช่ค่ะอ่าอ่าก็ตรงนี้แหละที่กูเอชอบนะ
ครับคือน้ำเนี่ยนักเรียนค่ะมีขึ้นแล้วก็
มีลงขึ้นลงนะคะ
บริเวณแล้วจะมีน้ำขึ้นกับน้ำลงแล้วก็เกาะ
ตรงนี้เขามีมีน้ำแบบใช้สีอะไรดีน่ะสี
เขียวแล้วกันน้ำแบบหลายอย่างเงี้ย
ไหลวนเราก็ออกไป
ไหนอ้วนอันนี้
แล้วก็ออกไปนะคะมันก็เลยพนามหลายวนแล้วก็
ออกไปน้ำแบบ
อ้าอะไรเข้ามาแล้วก็อร่อยออกไปครับตัวแรง
มากแรงมากขอวันที่ว่ายน้ำได้ไหมคะไว้ได้
ครับเก่งนี่ครับไม่สวยน่ะว่าไอ้หน้าไม่
โอเคเก็บไว้ให้ครับ
เก่งนิดหน่อยครับเก่งนิดหน่อยหาไม่ตรง
เนี้ยตรงเนี้ยดูไม่มีอะไรนะแต่น้ำแรงมาก
ต้องต้องมีเสื้อรถบอกเพราะว่ามันจะไหลออก
ไปข้างนอก
กับแต่พ่อน้ำแบบนี้ก็เลยมีตัวนี้ค่ะกูอัด
ถ้ามีอะไรครับว้าวด้วยไหมอันนี้เป็นประกา
รังหรือเป็นดอกไม้ทะเลปะการังอ่อนอ๋ออ๋อ
ปะการังอ่อน
สวยอันนี้ก็สวยมีหลายสีเลยได้ถามปกติเค้า
จะอยู่ลึกใช่ไหมคะ
มากขี่ประมาณซักมีน้ำ 4 เมตร 5 เมตร 10
เมตรแล้วต้องเกาะห้องนะดูละ 1 เมตร 2
เมตร
เขาว่าน้ำขึ้นน้ำลงในบางทีขึ้นท่วมห้องก็
ขึ้นสูงใช่ไหมคะเท่าไหร่เมตรเวลาลงลงๆก็
เหลือ 1  M  2 นี้
สวยนะก็เลยมีประการังน้ำลึกแต่ว่าไปตอน
ที่น้ำไม่ลึกใครก็ได้ง่ายๆโอเคแล้วก็แถว
นี้นอกจากปะการังอ่อนสีสีแบบนี้นะคะสีส้ม
สีชมพูสีชมพูอ่อนเนี่ยเออ
เนี่ยก็ติดปากกำลังอ่อน
อันนี้ดอกไม้ทะเลปะการังปะการังอ่อนมี
หลายสีมากเลยสวยจังแล้วก็มีอันนี้ด้วย
อุ้ยอันนี้เป็นแมลงอยู่หรือเป็นดอกไม้
หนอนเอาจะนอนล่ะครับอ่ะคะเรียกว่าหนอน
หนอนสนนอนนอนได้เลยนะนอนผู้ชาติหนอนสน
ฉัตรออกก็มันต้องตนนะอ้าเหมือนต้นสนที่มี
ขัดเป็นชั้นๆมีใบเป็นชั้นๆขึ้นไปเรียกว่า
เป็นฉัตรได้อ่ากับเนื้อนะคะก็เป็นหนอน
เป็นหนอนที่สวย
กินได้มั้ยสวยจังคิดไม่ได้
กินไม่ได้แล้วอย่าไปจับด้วยนะคะ
คือถ้าจับเขาก็เข้าไปข้างในแต่ถ้าครู
ปาร์ตี้แพ้จับแล้วแพ้ก็จะข้ามไม่ได้หรอ
โอเคมันหนึ่งขนมนะเหมือนเหมือนขนมของไทย
ขนมอะไรอ่ะคือขนมอาลัวมั้ยก็ใช้คิด
ให้คล้ายๆเห็นแล้วอยากกินขนมอาลัวเลยโอเค
ก็มีหลายสีขอด้วยๆมีขนม 1 อย่างนะคะนัก
เรียนวันๆนะคะชื่ออาล้วนหน้าตาแบบนี้ค่ะ
โอช่างคิดมากกว่าเต้แล้วก็มีตัวนี้ขวดตี
วิธีเปิดดีเห็นปลา
ใช่ๆการ์ตูนใช่ค่ะแล้วก็ดอกไม้ทะเลครับ
นิดดอกไม้ทะเลปลาการ์ตูน
ปลาการ์ตูนเอ่อตี้คิดว่าตอนนี้คนไทยเรียก
ปลาการ์ตูนเรียกว่าปลานีโม่กันหมดแล้ว
ครับทำไมอ่ะก็ไม่มีการ์ตูนชื่อ Nemo อ๋อ
ขอตาเหมือนปลาตัวเนี้ย
เอาไว้ Disney ใช่มั้ยให้ๆเด็กๆก็เลย
เรียกปลานีโม่ปลานีโม่หมดเลยตอนนี้จริงๆ
ชื่อการ์ตูน
การ์ตูนชื่อภาษาอังกฤษแล้วก็ไม่ทราบนะคะ
แม่เราเลี้ยงปลาการ์ตูน
หนังก็ออกอยู่ที่นี่โม้
ตรงนี้ไปด้วยเคยพูดหรือยังตรงหาดตรงไหน
ตรงนี้ค่ะของดอกไอ้ตัวนี้เรียกว่าดอกไม้
ทะเลนะคะดอกไม้ทะเลหาอย่าไปจับนะคะทำไม
อ่ะครับเป็นยังไงกูที่ไม่เคยจับเคยเห็น
แต่ว่าไม่เคยจับเพราะเขาบอกว่าเวลาเวลาดำ
น้ำดูประการังห้ามจัดได้ว่าจะเป็นไงเขา
บอกจะคันอ๋อจะคันคันคู๋นะเมื่อก่อนไม่รู้
ครั้งแรกที่ไปล่ะเอาหน้าโรงไป
ทำไมอ่ะมันนุ่มนะครับมันขึ้นบอก Soda รู้
ไงมันไม่ไม่เอาน่าเขาไม่ให้ใช้มือจับก่อน
หน้ามั้ย
แล้วเป็นไงครับแล้วเป็นไงคันไหมหน้ากูอีก
คงหนา
อาจจะโดนโดนน้อยไปโดนน้อยไปต้องโดนเยอะๆ
คู่เอกก็ไม่คันนะแต่เพื่อนน่ะอาจมีบางคน
น่ะไม่ใช่เพื่อนคนที่ไปด้วยกันนะคะเขาคัน
แล้วบอกท่านเอ๋ไม่เป็นอะไรแต่เสร็จแล้วก็
โดนโดนขวดทำนายไว้ได้อีห่าทำแบบนั้นไม่
ได้
ใช่ครับไม่ควรทำไว้กวนทำไม่ดีนะคะไม่ได้
ครับไอ้ที่บอกคือบอกให้รู้ว่าไม่ดี
แต่เขาไม่ได้ตายนะคะคือกูเองไม่ได้เอามือ
ไปจับแล้วเอาแค่หน้าไปซื้ออ๋อ
อยากรู้อยากรู้เฉยๆอ้าวต่อไปค่ะอ่ะมีประ
การังอันนี้ด้วย
เกอันนี้รู้สึกว่ามันจะแข็งใช่ไหมครับวัน
นี้ให้อ้ายแข็งไม่อ่อนไม่ใช่ปะการังอ่อน
และค่ะเป็นประการังเขากวางอ้าใช่ครับดู
แล้วเหมือนเขากว่าเหมือนใครกวางเยอะๆ
เอ็กซ์ๆๆ
ก็อาจจะอยู่บริเวณนี้นะคะเขาความจะอยู่
บริเวณตรงนี้จะเป็นลบจะมีครับอุ้ย
เขากวางก็จะอยู่อยู่แถวเนี้ย
แถวนี้แต่พับผ้าสวยๆจะอยู่แถวนี้
นะคะ
ถ้าชอบนะคะคนชอบประการังเนอะรีบมาเยอะไหม
ครับครัวตีเห็นปลาเยอะเลยชอบครับพ่อเป็น
นำน้ำดูปะการังชอบเหมือนกันน้ำน้ำก็ก็มี
ปลาเยอะค่ะคือจริงๆเขาจะมีประตูนอื่นๆนะ
บางคนถ่ายรูปมาจากปลาเยอะมากไม่อาหารไป
ให้ปลาอะไรก็มีอาหารไปดูใกล้ปลาจะได้มา
เยอะๆใช่มะมาร์จินอาหารกันนะไม่ควร
ให้ให้ปลาเข้าไปทำให้ทวนหือไม่ควรแปลว่า
ไม่ทำหน้าไม่ดีอย่าไปทำคะแล้วก็มีเกาะใน
กระบี่หาดจังหวัดกระบี่จะมีตัวนี้ออกเยอะ
แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับทะเลต้องระวังนิดนึง
อะไรอ้าอันนี้งูแน่เลยโกโรตีเห็นเหมือนกู
จะมีก็ยังสีสวยอยู่ดีเกิดที่เห็นงูสวย
ก็จะสวยไงตัวเล็กๆสีสวยอยู่ดีครับ
เป็นงูทะเล
มันอยู่ในทะเลใช่มั้ยก็เลยเรียกงูทะเล
อยู่ในทะเลงูทะเลเค้าก็ไม่ได้เร็วมากแล้ว
ก็จะช้าของเขาอ่ะไม่ค่อยๆน้ำไป
ถ้าเราว่ายน้ำอยู่แล้วครบพวกเราต้องรีบ
หนีนะหลบไปขอกูเอาหน้าไปถูอีกไหมครับมาๆ
กูเองเคยเห็นที่เกาะห้องอ่ะ 1 ครั้งตัวบ่
เคยเห็นที่ที่เกาะพีพีอีก 1 ครั้งขอ EP
ก็อยู่กระบี่นะคะหาอยู่ก็เห็นปลาป่วยเอก
ก็ว่ายน้ำออกไปไกล
ไม่อยู่ใกล้ๆทุกคนถาม a ไปไหนบอกไม่เป็น
ไรเอกชอบตรงนู้นอ้าวไม่บอกเพื่อนแล้วว่า
มีงู
Mail เพื่อนอ่ะดูเพื่อนนะดูไอ้โง่ทำไมดี
ใจไม่ดีจะ
เพื่อนก็บอกว่าครูเอกกลัวมากเกินไปอ๋อ
โอกาสที่จะพุ่งขึ้นมาแล้วเวลาจะกลับเขา
ต้องอ่าปากแบบนี้ใช่ไหมกับเราไม่ได้
กัดไม่ทันใช่มั้ยเพราะว่ามีน้ำมีน้ำอยู่ 5
ปากน้ำเข้าไป
แต่ก็กลัวไหมอ่ะกลัวก็ควรจะกลัวครับควรจะ
กลัวเพราะว่ามันกลับแล้วมันก็ตายนะให้
หน้าเรานะกูไม่ตายเราตายค่าหวยอยู่ในทะเล
ใช่ไหมกว่าจะไปหาหมอนาน
งั้นเนี่ยครูเอกก็เลยแบบท่านบอกไปดำน้ำ
เนี่ยนำน้ำกลางวันโอเคไอ้ดำน้ำกลางคืน
แล้วไม่เอาโอเคเพราะว่าเขาจะมีอะไรนะดำ
น้ำตอนกลางวันกับดำน้ำตอนกลางคืนใช่มั้ย
ฮะอ่ะกลางคืนมันมองไม่เห็นไงใช่ครับมอง
เห็นนิดหน่อยคือมีไฟที่เราแต่ว่าไม่มีรอบ
รอบๆก็ไม่เอาคือจะสวยนะคะนั่นจากเกาะห้อง
พาประกอบนี้ค่ะกว่าตี้รู้จักนี่ไปที่ไหน
ครับ
พี่ๆ PP โอเคก็พี่ๆนักเรียนหลายคนรู้จัก
เกาะพีพีแน่เลย
อะตี้เคยที่ไม่เคยไปไม่เคยไปเกาะพีพีไม่
เคยไปกระบี่
ต้องไปค่ะโปรแกรมหน้านะคะผัวติ
เอ่อเอ่อกระบี่หัวตี้ไปไปภูเก็ตไป
ไปพังงาแต่ว่าไม่ได้ไปกระบี่อยู่ใกล้จริง
มันก็อยู่ใกล้ๆกันแต่ใครไม่ถึงแต่ปกติคน
จะไปผีๆเขาจะไปภูเก็ต
กลับก็นั่งเรือจากภูเก็ตไปพีพีไม่ไป
กระบี่แล้วนั่งเรือจากกระบี่ไป TP
คือก็งงนะคะนักเรียนกูเองก็งงนะคะเวลาจะ
ไปเที่ยวพีพีคือไปลงภูเก็ตแล้วก็นั่งเรือ
ไปอยู่เค้าเป็นเกาะของกระบี่จังหวัด
กระบี่แต่ว่าไปจาก PP ง่ายๆไปจากภูเก็ต
ง่ายกว่า
แต่ถ้าเราอยู่ไปเที่ยวกระบี่แล้วก็นั่ง
เรือจากกระบี่ไปพีพีก็ได้ไม่ได้เหมือนกัน
เอ้อครับก็พีจะมีตรงนี้ชื่อพีพีดอนนะคะ
และก็จะมีมีมีโรงแรมและด้านนี้จะมีโรงแรม
มีร้านอาหารเขาจะดำน้ำกันตรงนี้แถวนี่
ดำน้ำตรงนี้แล้วก็ตรงนี้ปั๊มน้ำใกล้ๆเลย
ใช่ไหมครับไม่ต้องนั่งเรือไปเลยใกล้ๆเลย
เหมือนนิดเดียวนักเรียนนิดหน่อยมาเลยนิด
หน่อยนะคะน่าจะไปท่านถ้าจะดำน้ำจากตรงนี้
ออกไปน่ะที่ต้องว่ายน้ำเก่งหรอกอ๋ออ๋อ
ครับว่ายน้ำเหนื่อยนะคะส่วนใหญ่เขาก็จะ
เอาเรือมาให้มาทิ้งตรงเนี้ยแล้วเราก็ไป
น้ำจากตรงนี้เข้ามา
ด้านนี้กูเอกเคยไปหนึ่งครั้ง
สวยเหมือนกันนะคะแต่แต่ว่าไม่เคยไปดำน้ำ
ตรงนี้ไปแค่บริเวณนี้นะคะแล้วก็ตรงนี้ตรง
นี้ตรงนี้ก็มีกรรมนี่ตรงนี้มีอะไรให้ดู
นี่อ่ะไม่มีอะไรครับตรงนี้จะเป็นเดี๋ยวนะ
[เพลง]
ขอลงไปทั้งนั้นก่อนนะคะ
มีลิงอ๋ออ๋อมีลิงมีลิงอยู่ที่ที่บนเกาะ
ครับมีลิงค์อยู่บนเกาะพีพีดอนมีค่ะ
ดีนะคะพีพีดอนบริเวณตรงนี้หัว Arty ถ้าไป
ต้องระวังนะเป็นลิงปลิงทะเลไหม
ไม่ใช่ไหมจังอ่ะลิงกังลิงกลางลิเก
คือมันเป็นลิงที่มันไม่ขอโทษนะคะลิงเรา
เรียกมันนะคะ
ตัดได้ใช่กับไม่นิสัยไม่ดีตนด้วยใช่ไหม
เกเรใช่ไหมเรียกว่าเกเรได้ไหมพี่เลทถ้า
ครู Arty ไปนอนปูเสื่อแล้วก็นอนอ่าแล้ว
ลิงไปทำอะไรครับวิ่งก็จะมาแล้วก็ขโมยข้อ
หวัดดีกินอ๋ออ๋อก็ 4 ของพิมพ์ขโมยของด้วย
ใช่ไหมใช่เขาเปิดได้ให้ด้วยนะกว่าตี้โอ้
ลิงสลาดนะลิงเก่ง
คุยเคยไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนมาก่อนไปทำงานก็
ไม่เห็นจะตอนหลังไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนเป็น
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิง 3 คน
ผู้หญิงไอ้นายหาก็ก็นั่งอยู่ใช่ไหมว่า
นั่งปั๊บก็เห็นผู้ชายเดินมาแล้วก็มองหน้า
ตาน่ากลัวกูเอกเอ้ยผู้ชายมาบอกอะไรเลย
เพื่อนเอาสวยไงเราก็ใส่ชุดไว้น้ำคูเองใส่
ชุดแบบนี้ดีกินอ่าชุดว่ายน้ำเป็นบิกินี่
แบบนี้
ไว้หลามถามเพื่อนเราสวยแล้วก็คิดทำไมผู้
ชายมามองใครก็มองตลอดแล้วก็ตกใจนิดหน่อย
นะคะอ่าเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยเพราะเพื่อนก็ลงไป
ว่ายน้ำคู่เอกก็จะลงผู้ชายก็เดินเข้ามา
พี่บอกว่าพี่ครับพี่ครับพี่
ครับ
มีหนึ่งคนดูของนะครับอ๋อ
อะไรนะคะมันจะมีลิงลงมาเนี่ยผมต้องถือไม้
เอาไว้ไล่ลิงลิงไปอ๋อ
ไม่อย่างงั้นน่ะลิงจะมาขโมยขออวยของอ้า
ต้องมีคนคอยดูด้วยคนนึงโอเคใช่ก็คือต้อง
จับของไว้เลยอะไม่งั้นเขาจะมาขโมยนะเขา
ขโมยกล้องถ่ายรูปขโมยกระเป๋า
แต่ว่าถ้าเรามีโค้กเป๊ปซี่เขาก็จะเปิดกิน
เลย
ว้าวลิงๆฉลาดค่ะตลาดด้วยอ่ะเปิดเป๊ปซี่
กินได้เคเธอเจ้าของตัวเองได้ค่ะอาต่อไป
ค่ะอันนี้ค่อยดูอันนี้อันนี้ก็เป็น PP
เหมือนกันหอมนี้ลงมาข้างล่างแล้วอยู่บน
ชายหาด TP
ถ้าเป็นของพีพีเลค่ะคือเกาะพีพีเขาเรียก
หมู่เกาะน้องจะมีพีพีดอนแล้วก็ผิดอีเล
อันนี้ก็บอกชื่อเอาไหมอ่าเคยได้ยินไหมก็
ได้ยิน The  Beach  5 ใช้ครับอ่าวมาหยา
ทำไมอยากอุ้ยตอนสึนามิมาได้เข้ามาตรงนี้
ด้วยนะเข้ามาตรงนี้แหละ
จะต้องนี้เคยมีสีนามิเข้านะคะนักเรียนอ่ะ
อ้าวมาอย่าสวยนะคะตรงนี้ครูเอ๋ยังไม่เคย
ไป
แต่เขาบอกสวยมากตอนนี้ก็มีถั่วเอามาอย่า
แบบที่เคยไปคือตรงนี้
มีอะไรครับเป็นเกาะพีพีเหมือนกันแต่เป็น
พีพีเลแล้วก็เรือจะจอดตรงนี้ได้
เรือจะจอดตรงนี้แล้วก็ขึ้นตรงนี้เป็นถ้ำ
ที่ถ้างั้นไปอยู่ในถ้ำครับมีอันนี้ค่ะมี
รังนก
รังนกเป็นแบบนี้นกนางแอ่นจะมีเนี่ยชายอะ
เนี่ยนกนางแอ่นแล้วก็มีรังนก
แพะกลิ่นได้อ๋ออ๋อกินได้ใช่ไหมครับเอามา
ต้มใช่มั้ยบ้ายใช่อันเนี้ยรังนกนะคะนัก
เรียนจะอยู่ในเนื้อค่ะอยู่ในถ้ำตรงเนี้ย
แล้วเขาก็จะมีม้ไผ่แบบนี้ค่ะเนี่ยเค้าจะ
ปีนปีนปีนปีนปีนขึ้นไปแล้วก็เก็บรังนก
ไปดูได้นะคะแต่จะเห็นหรือเปล่าไม่ทราบนะ
คะเพราะมันมืดแบบนะคะมืด
ไปดูนกนางแอ่นหรือไปดูรังหน่อยดูรางนกรัง
นกอ่ะโอเคก็สายไฟแบบนี้ผัวอาทิตย์ก็จะ
เห็นแบบนี้จะมีจะมีไฟถายกับใครคือแบบนี่
นาเพราะว่าในถ้ำอันมืดใช่ไหมได้ทำมันมืด
เอาก็มีไฟฉายเพื่อจะส่องก็ไปเพื่อให้เห็น
เห็นรังนกรังนกถ้ามีก็เก็บถ้าไม่มีก็ไม่
เก็บก็คือต้องเสียตังค์ขึ้นนะคะสวยงามนะ
คะไม่ฟรีเท่าไหร่ไม่แน่ใจจำไม่ได้นะฮะนาน
แล้วค่ะนักเรียนครูเอกไปตอนอายุ 18  19
ถึง 21 ปี
ใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนทำงานก็ต้องไป 19  20  21
แล้วก็ไม่บายที่ทำงานไปทำที่อื่นก็เลยไม่
ได้ไปนะคะรังนกก็จะเป็นแบบนี้นี่อ้านี้
คือซ่อมเสร็จแล้วพร้อมที่จะกินได้แล้วใช่
ไหมครับได้กว่าที่กินไหมคนที่เคยกินครับ
เคยกินชอบไหมค่ะกอบ
ก็เฉยเฉยๆเฉยๆเฉยๆกินเศษก็ได้ไม่กินก็ได้
ไม่เป็นไร
คือเขาบอกว่ากินอะไรก็กินแต่ไม่รู้สึกว่า
รังนกหลังดู
อาครูเอกก็
ค่อยกิน
กินน่าจะ 2 ครั้งได้มันค่ะ 2 หรือ 3
ครั้งหรืออ่ะเป็นรังนกจริงๆน่าจะ 1 ครั้ง
ที่เหลือก็คือรังนกไม่เจ็บ
ไม่ได้กินที่นี่กินที่กรุงเทพฯนะคะแต่ไม่
ใช่รังนกหรอกน่าจะเป็นวุ้น
เพราะว่ารังนกจริงๆเวลากินแล้วมีกลิ่นตาย
ได้มั้ยมีกลิ่นนะมันทีเอาข่าวนี้หน่อยเออ
กูเองไม่ชอบน่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นหลังลบที่ไม่ใช่
รังนกอ่ะกินได้
นำนกปลอมได้แล้วเป็นวุ้นเป็น The  Series
เป็นวุ้นเนี้ยกินได้
การ์ดตกพีพีเลนะคะก็จะเป็นนางนกตั้งแต่
เราเข้าไปดูได้แอนด์เคที่นี้เรายังมีเวลา
นิดหน่อยใช่ไหมคะมีอะไรมีนิดนึงอ้ะไปไหน
ครับอีกที่นึงมา
อันนี้เป็นที่กระบี่เหมือนกันนะคะอุ้ย
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่เห็นมีคนกำลังเกาะอยู่ตรง
นั้นด้วยกำลังเก็บรังนกอ่ะครับไม่ใช่ค่ะ
นี่ไม่ได้เก็บรังนกใช่ไหมสำหรับคนชอบตื่น
เต้นขอ
เขาปีนผาาปีหน้าผาขึ้นไปทีกันก็ตรงนี้
เป็นชื่อหาดหาดไร่เลย์มากไรเรไรเรื่อยๆนะ
อาจไหล่เลหาดราไวย์หาดหน้าแถวนั้นมีอาจ
เยอะใช่ไหมเราก็มีมีหน้าผายปีนโอเคมีลาภ
ผ่านแล้วก็เป็นแบบนี้
เคยไหมคะขออัดกูไม่เคยอยากลองไหมคะตัวนี้
คิดว่ามันน่าจะอันตรายนะ
น่าจะอ่านตอนลายน่ะ
น้องฝึกนะต้องไปเรียนก่อนนะคะได้ครับไม่
ต้องแข็งแรงมากๆด้วยใจครับ
ก็อันนี้ก็จะเป็นอ่ะที่ที่กระบี่เหมือน
กันถ้าใครชอบเป็นผาเขาก็มีหน้าผาให้ปีน
แต่บางคนก็บอกว่ากูเองไม่แน่ใจนะคะบางคน
ก็บอกว่าตอนนี้แถวนี้ก็มีเหมือนกันอ๋อ
แล้วครูยังไม่แน่ใจอันนี้นะคะแต่ว่าถ้าใน
จังหวัดกระบี่นะคะถ้าตรงนี้เลยเนี่ยที่
หาดไรเลย์น่ะก็มีเลยแน่นอนใต้ไปขายนะคะ
ก็วันนี้ก็พานักเรียนไปเที่ยวกระบี่
กระบี่เป็นเมืองที่มีเกาะเกาะเยอะๆเยอะ
มากงั้นก็เป็นวันนี้ก็รู้จักค่า
ผู้ชายหาดไรเลย์นะคะได้ครับที่ดอนมีลิงนะ
คะเกาะนี้ตั้งหน้ารังนกเพลงรังนกที่
พีพีเลนะคะเป็นค่ำกับตาก็อันนี้ก็อ้าวมา
อย่าหนัง
แล้วก็เกาะพีพีดอน
แล้วก็ไปดูปะการัง
ปะการังเขากวาง
Nemo นีโมปลาการ์ตูนโอเค
แล้วก็ไปเกาะห้องเกาะห้องมีในห้องแล้วก็
มีนอกข้องด้วยโอเค
ถ้าได้เปลี่ยนมาเมืองไทยเนาะมาเมืองไทย
แล้วอยากจะไปเองไปกระบี่มีอะไรก็รู้จัก
สองก่อนละ 2 เกาะกับ 1 หาดแล้วนะคะต่อ
ห้องเกาะพีพีนะคะสำหรับคนชอบว่ายน้ำไป
ลดน้ำหนักๆๆ
กว่าตี้โปรแกรมต่อไปต้องไปนะคะถ้ามีโอกาส
ถ้ามีโอกาสคิดว่าจะไปครับที่กระบี่กลับ
จากภูเก็ตนั่งเรือไปก็น่าจะประมาณ 2  2
ชั่วโมงหรือ 3 ชั่วโมง
3 ชั่วโมงนานมากทั้งนั่งเรือ 3 ชั่วโมง
เพราะว่าเรือเวลานั่งแล้วมันจะร้องมี
คลื่นใช่ 3 งานมากถ้าไปเกาะห้อง 3
ชั่วโมงแน่ๆพีน่าจะประมาณ 2 นะคะ 2 กว่า
โอเคครับโอเคค่ะคลิปนี้ครูเอกกับกูอะตี้
ก็กดเวลาหมดเวลาแล้วครับหมดเวลาแล้ว
เดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเราจะผ้ากันไปเที่ยวที่ไหน
ครับกลับมาติดตามกันนะครับแล้วพบกันคราว
หน้าครับวันนี้ควรที่รักพี่เอกลาไปก่อน
ครับสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สุดคำนักเรียนบ๊าย
บายน
ม.ค